from time to time our Board of Governors
Awards an Oscar and recognition of an
entire body of work and to present that
award tonight is a woman who has won two
Best Actress Oscars herself ladies and
gentlemen here is Sally Field
[Applause]
[Music]
we usually think of special Oscars as
awards given to individuals whose
careers are behind them who are
contemplating retirement well tonight's
recipient is hardly ready to retire in
fact he is at this very moment on a film
set in Chicago working on the color of
money a sequel of sorts to the film The
Hustler in which he starred over 20
years ago in his 30 years as an actor
director and producer Paul Newman has
provided us so many memorable screen
moments it would be impossible to
present them in anything less than a
three hours special as an actor Newman
began his professional career working
regularly in the television anthologies
of the 50s Playhouse 90 US Steel hour
the Philco Playhouse from there he moved
to Broadway and soon after to Hollywood
with his portrayal of rocky Graziano in
somebody up there likes me
audiences and critics began to take
notice it was for the hustler that he
won his second best Oscar nomination
soon he was nominated again for his role
of the Texas he'll HUD then his career
took a new turn when he directed his
wife Joanne Woodward in Rachel Rachel
that won Newman the New York Film
Critics Best Director award and a Best
Actress nomination for miss Woodward
among his many movies is a picture I
know something about called absence of
malice but these are all just titles and
when it comes to Paul Newman's type
titles really doesn't tell very much
currently work in Chicago I am proud to
be able to present via satellite
this special Academy Award on which is
inscribed to Paul Newman and recognition
of his many memorable and compelling
screen performances and for his personal
integrity and dedication to his craft
[Applause]
ah thank you for being there ah I
certainly want to thank the members of
the Academy and I'm especially grateful
that this did not come wrapped as a gift
certificate to forest long Spencer Tracy
so the legend goes was accosted by a
young man who said I'm going to be an
actor and crazy replied that's terrific
just don't let them catch you at it
ah I don't know where I am on the
learning curve but I do know that
tonight is provided a lot of nourishment
and um kind of permission I think to
risk and maybe surprise myself a little
bit in the hope that my best work is
down the pike in front of me and not in
back of me thank you
[Applause]
what
that's where you can get it
you